Jack Reacher est décédé une
étoile de bronze de l'armée serrée, une étoile d'argent et un
cœur violet quand le nom de Dieu est un gars comme ça qui
fait margrave qu'est-ce qu'un gars comme ça
fait en prison les fermetures éclair les
poignets ne lui convenaient pas vous les gars recyclez
sept corps depuis que vous vous êtes mis  un pied dans ma
ville
j'ai été arrêté pour meurtre maintenant tu veux
mon aide je veux que tu fasses ce que je dis tu
vas juste où tu veux quand tu
veux tout le monde est toujours jaloux je vais
découvrir toute cette opération
et la réduire en cendres
vous les gars  Sais ce qui va
t'arriver tu pars maintenant
tueurs froids
alors soyez intelligents n'enfreignez pas la loi et
promettez-moi que vous ne finirez pas dans une autre
cellule de détention
y a commencé
[Musique]
tu es sur le point de te faire botter le cul non
je vais juste casser les mains de trois
enfants ivres nous sommes quatre l'un de vous
doit conduire à l'hôpital
[Musique]
ce n'est pas une émission déformée
hors de
toi